- I can imagine what
it's about a little bit
but will you tell us
like the premise of it?
- Yeah. Well,
I'm like an Indian nerd so
when I have a show called
"The Sex Lives of College Girls",
which is what the show is about,
it makes you think,
"Oh, did you have a sex life in college?"
Which I did not.
- Oh, yeah.
- But...
- I was nerdy too.
- I was nerdy. So like...
But I loved "Sex and the
City", I loved the "Showgirls".
And I just think that I went
to college on the east coast
and it just seemed like such a fun,
I hadn't, there weren't a
lot of shows about that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it just seemed like a really fun,
juicy title but I'm a prude
because I can barely say
the title without laughing
- [Kelly] (laughs) You giggled. Yeah.
- Yeah. I giggle every time-
- Yeah.
- embarrassed of the show.
- Not the show, of the title of the show.
- Yeah.
- So I'm like, you know,
I'm still getting used to it now.
- It's fun though,
and I think also it's probably fun
for people to watch now, too.
'Cause it's like, wow, yesteryear,
when you could actually
hang out with people
and go to parties,
it's like different now-
- Yeah.
- 'cause of COVID.
So it's actually awesome to see
just people hanging out together
on college campus. (laughs)
- Yeah.
Well, shooting a show where it's called
"The Sex Lives of College Girls",
so there's like sexy situations
which are impossible
to shoot during COVID.
So there would, everyone
had to be tested 500 times-
- Yeah.
- and it's just like,
very awkward.
And then it's one thing
if you're one of the performers in it,
you have to be there.
But when you're just a producer for a show
that's about sex and you're
just watching it on a monitor
and be like, "Yeah, yeah, this is good."
You're like, "Am I like a pervert?"
Like, what's...
(Kelly laughing)
Is this...
- Should we be watching?
- Should I be watching this?
These like, it's college
age people making out
and I'm like observing it and being like,
"No, no, no,
(Kelly laughing)
more thrusting this time."
So, I...
- It's for the art.
- It's for the art,
heavier breathing please.
So I...
- Oh my God.
- Yeah. So it's been an
awkward journey. (laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
For me to be...
- It looks like a funny
show though. I love it.
- [Mindy] I think it's
gonna be really fun.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
I am a person where like
I just wanted to laugh when I turn on TV.
- Amen, yeah.
- I just wanna see something
that's not going to depress me.
Life is so hard for everyone.
- Yeah.
- Everyone's just like trying
to get by, especially now.
- Yeah.
- And so
I wanted to do something that
was really funny and was like,
I don't know, kind of felt...
- Escapism.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Wish fulfillment. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.